thank you thank you very much for the
warm introduction it's an honor to be
here and participate in this lecture
series I want to first clear up any
possible misconceptions I have one kid
just one and he has one head this was
this two-headed thing was taken with
photo booth on the iPad and it's his
favorite thing to do is to take pictures
of himself with two heads so anyway
that's impossible and he's thinking
about it okay all right
all right okay so so I have two goals
for this talk and they're kind of
conflicting a little bit so the first
goal is I want to tell you about the
state of the art in in circuit
complexity lower bounds in what
particular areas of certain complexity
at least and the second goal is to give
a general thought for a scientific
audience so I'm I'm going to try to
navigate these two things and hopefully
it will turn out okay all right let's
begin so as a young computer science
theorist one is taught that there are
roughly two kinds of people there are
algorithms people and there are
complexity people okay the algorithms
designers asked the following very
positive upbeat questions they asked
when can we solve problems quickly what
can we do with computers when can we
find a good algorithm what what does
good mean good could mean many sorts of
things generally speaking it means that
your algorithm is time efficient it runs
very fast okay on the other hand there's
this other group of people called
complexity theorists okay the complexity
theorists are negative nancies they ask
where our problem is difficult to solve
okay when when can we prove the problem
is not easy okay in more slightly more
technical terms
when can we prove a lower bound
on the amount of time that we need to
solve a problem or the amount of
resources needed to be consumed in order
to solve a problem so so this sort of
lower bound thing versus algorithms
think it's going to be pretty prevalent
this talk so here are some intuitions
about theory that you build up again as
a young computer scientist you learned
that the elegant design and the
complexity theorists have opposing goals
and tasks okay certainly the way I
presented it I mean one is trying to say
there's an algorithm the other ones
trying to say nope you know so so the
way I presented there really a opposite
to each other okay and the second thing
you learn when way or another so the
algorithms tribe has an easier life
somehow somehow designing algorithms is
just much easier than proving lower
balance and this intuition is really
really strong I mean you want to say
look if I design an algorithm I just
have to give you one piece of code it's
just going to work and solve the problem
no matter what but if just to show a
lower bound I have to show that no
matter what code you wrote down even
code I will never see like just there's
just only so much code I could see in my
life oh well no matter what you write
down it's just not going to work it's
just not going to solve the problem fast
enough so just from that point of view
it seems designing Aram's is easier okay
so some of our lower bound says have you
have to reason about all possible
algorithms right so I assume many of you
know about algorithms so I'll spend some
time talking more about lower bounds at
least the beginning so the most famous
lower bound question the Grandmamma of
them all is P equals NP okay and just to
give you a very high-level idea of what
P and NP are not to go in the
definitions NP is the set of problems
where verifying a solution to the
problem is easy and P are the problems
where finding a solution is easy to do
okay
and so by easy we mean the following
technical sense of Paul
meal time so there's some algorithm that
on inputs of length n runs in some
polynomial and an amount of steps think
of this P of n is N squared or in cubed
something like that so this is what we
mean by easy most of the things that you
see when you're learning our than
they're easy sorting easy so this
problem was articulated in 1970s by
Steve cook and the carp and also in the
Soviet Union by leonid 11 okay so the
rather than going into definitions and
things like this I will just give you an
illustration of this and probably the
best illustration of the difference
between P and NP is the problem of
factoring numbers so suppose I give you
this number okay
it's 232 digits and I want you to I want
to know like x and y so the x times y
equals this number okay
well turns out there are two such
numbers okay
X of this length Y of this length all
right now the problem of giving such a
number what are x and y right so this is
an EMPI problem because if I gave you x
and y to begin with if I gave you the
solution of the problem the X and the y
then it's easy to check that next times
y equals the given number you can
definitely multiply these things in less
than a second on your cellphone check
they equal the number okay
what about finding the x and y given
just this number what can you do well I
gave you a very special number here
actually so this is the RSA 768 number
it took two years and a team of number
theorists and programmers to find this
X&Y a lot of famous people
crushed really really hard to find this
X&Y despite the fact that once it's
given to me takes no time at all to
verify their items okay so in so MP is
this kind of problem where you I give
you the number and I want to know the
two the two factors x and y well with P
you just you know I'm just
I just want to like find the answer okay
so the problem of people's emptiness
asking whenever it's possible to check
that x times y equals a number could I
find could I do the inverse and figure
out x and y efficiently as well okay so
this is a very stark contrast between
these two kinds of problems okay so P
equals NP is asking a verifying a
solution a problem is easy to do then
can we find a solution the problem also
easily so here's another number okay
it's been slightly longer it's 240
decimal digits alright so we don't
actually don't know how to factor this
number well okay as far as we know
perhaps our friends the NSA have
factored this number a long time ago
okay and and if you want to you know a
bigger list of numbers that we don't
know how to factor there's a whole page
and Wikipedia with lots and lots of
numbers going up about six hundred
digits big lists of numbers
okay so if we could factor integers
easily so this problem is looks a simple
number theoretic problem but you
probably know that if we could factor
these interests easily we could break
all our essay based cryptography so we
could break anything that says there's
just a little lock here on your web
browser yeah
forget it it's not really I mean this is
crack it open okay well HTTPS SSL
totally broken
okay these are as same numbers actually
is a great resource for someone like me
if someone send emails me and say they
have a proof people's MP I just
forwarding this link and say I'll be
waiting you know just all you got to do
just tell me these you know short 100
something digit numbers from everything
in this list
okay then oh then I read your paper okay
so so that that makes them so very very
makes it easy for me right okay so we
believe the answer is no okay hope this
is you know somewhat convincing just
this this problem of multiplication
versus factoring a number but how that
we mathematically prove that how could
we prove there's just no way to do it
there's no way to break a number in the
protectors we have to show that some
problem that's easy to verify it somehow
impossible to efficiently solve okay so
this requires us to somehow reason about
all easy programs one way or another so
let me emphasize it P where's MP is only
one of many questions of this kind many
of which just I simply can't mention
this talk I just want to mentioned the
most prominent one there but they all
sort of hint or at the same kind of
thing reasoning about efficient
computation we don't know how to do it
okay so where lower bounds good for so
they're impossibilities they'll say you
can't do something well the first sort
of very useful way in which the lower
bounds were uses for algorithm
engineering so if I prove that a lower
bound on a particular mathematical
formalization or a problem that just
often just means that the way you set
the problem formally is not the right
sort of way it's math it just not going
to help you if you try for all this if
you set if you wrote the problem down in
this way so so you could try something
else you try to read for me at the
problem go back to it and and see if you
can steer yourself away from things
which MP hard and things which are more
like P but lower bounds have actually
been extremely useful in other areas
such as machine learning theory useful
in in learning functions for which you
know lower bounds for those kinds of
functions for cryptography as as
demonstrated with RSA so you sort of
need lower bounds just to get off the
ground you need to be able to say that
you know I have have concocted a problem
efficiently but you you can't crack it
you can't you know turn around and solve
it for me and also more grounds come up
in an unexpected way and the
construction of so-called pseudo-random
generators so these come up when you
have a randomized algorithm arete the
album which tosses coins and you can
argue that you can mathematically prove
that okay if you have uniform
independent random coins then this
algorithm is going to work
well maybe maybe you know you can't rely
on independent random coins well lower
bounds can actually be used to remove
the randomness from algorithms replace
randomized armed systematically with
something that just uses a purely
deterministic sequence of coin flips and
still works well this is a very nice
connection and sort of unexpected when
you first think about it
but one day I really want to try at home
is that we don't really know what all
lower bounds are good for because we
have no idea what the proofs of them
look like okay I mean this almost all
this is just from sort of knowing just
that the lower bound holds what you can
do but what if you actually had a
mathematical proof something that
actually did the reasoning and you could
study it then there's no telling what we
could we could learn about computation
that way and so lower balance to me are
one of the great scientific mysteries of
our time there are conjectures about
them everywhere ok Internet security
relies on them being true but knowing
them for sure is mostly inaccessible to
us ok so so yeah this is just a great
mystery why is easy computation so hard
to understand
okay why are lower bound so hard to
prove well why are we so stuck here so
actually we have a pretty good
understanding of why we're stuck so
there are many known nogo theorems in
complexity theory with various technical
names cultivation natural proofs algebra
zation so on what they say in a nutshell
is that the common proof techniques that
we use are just not going to be enough
to prove things much much weaker than p9
wimpy things much weaker than this
just like very simple things we can't we
can't prove allowance for and this has
cost a great deal of weeping and wailing
and gnashing of teeth a great pessimism
in complexity theory and so the big
question here is how will we make
progress how do we get smarter how are
we going to get off the ground and start
really proving that some problems are
hard to solve ok so so this
is what I'm going to try to say
something about okay I mean obviously I
don't have all the answers but I would
like to say something that I hope can be
conveyed to everyone yeah well sort of
the main insights in work that I
participate in so far is in connections
between arms and lower bounds so we're
talking about how arm designs are the
easier life then lower bound improvers
in fact we are deep connections between
the two subjects that we just don't
understand yet we know for sure that
they are there we have sort of glimpses
of connections we but there is certainly
something more under the hood that we've
got to know and so I'll tell you about
the glimpses that we have so the main
idea I guess the one thing I would like
to you to try to take away from this
talk is this thing in this box designing
algorithms is as hard as proving lower
bounds sometimes now this is one of
those ideas that depending on who you
talk to is either complete heresy or
they thought of it already okay so that
means it's a good idea from from my from
my informal judgment okay so yeah so
it's a so it but it's sort of
provocative so it's very provocative
actually because if because lower bound
designer doesn't have it as hard as the
album designer okay so somehow the
design event certain algorithms is going
to actually give you lower bounds
so maybe the our designer doesn't have
it so easy after all it just
they managed to solve other problems or
maybe it's just psychological maybe we
just are wired to think about algorithms
and some you know more easily than lower
bounds but there's not so much different
between them in the end so here's here's
just that my vague attempt to draw some
parallel here
so a typical resultant album design says
here is an algorithm a that solves some
problem on all possible instances of the
problem now it's actually amazing how
many statements of this form hold but
the fact that like you can have a
algorithm that say solves a
a problem all possible graphs no matter
which graph you see even graphs you will
never be able to see you can still prove
it's going to work and give you the
right answer for this graph okay on all
possible instances okay now a typical
theorem from lower bounds will say
something like here is a proof P that
this problem can't be solved on all
possible by all above two albums of some
class some weak class of algorithms that
I've sort of box over here and I can
rule all of them out from solving this
problem here so what I would like to
promote is to draw a parallel between
the algorithm here in the album design
problem and the proof here in lower
bounds and all possible instances of the
problem in the album design problem with
all possible albums with some class okay
so you think about this it sort of
automatically suggests the kind of
algorithms we want to design so the kind
of problems we want to solve our
problems which take some kind of
algorithm as input itself and perform
some computation so we wanted to solve
some kind of problem that is taking an
algorithm at an input we have to be very
careful of how we do this I mean like if
you just took the usual kind of
algorithm as input like the sort of
terrain type algorithm then there are
lots of results an undergrad
computability theory that just says no
matter what you try to do analyzing the
things it's not going to work
so it's make this kind of connection
tractable we have to slightly change the
model of algorithm we're looking at and
this is what I'm going to talk about
okay so so I have a very high level very
high level here's the specific kind of
connection that I'm going to talk about
so suppose you have there exists some
non-trivial circuit analysis our okay so
think of this is just some albums some
fixed program maybe a Turing machine
what have you it receives as input some
circuit encoded in some nice way some
logical circuit and for all logical
circuits it can do the some kind of
non-trivial analysis on this thing let's
say it can determine whether that this
circuit is satisfiable in other words
whether the circuit is computing a
trivial
function or this computing something
interesting let's suppose I can do this
in some nice way
something just better than trying all
possible inputs to the circuit and
seeing what happens if you can set this
kind of thing of it you can solve this
kind of album design problem then you
can say there is a function f compute
with respect to certain Turing machines
for which for all circuits they cannot
compute this function for all circuits
that cannot compute this function so you
get circuit complexity lower amounts so
from the design of particular kinds of
algorithms problems ones which take as
some kind of algorithm or circuit as
input and analyzing them non trivially
you can then prove that for whatever it
is I analyzed non-trivial e I now have a
new function that can't be computed by
it so that this is a very very
counterintuitive if you look at it in
the wrong way if you look at it it's
quite a far away maybe it's so slightly
more into okay so this is the basic kind
of connection that I and others have
been able to draw and we've been able to
actually prove lower new lower bounds
new limits on computing using this kind
of connection so here's an outline for
the rest of the talk I'll give you a
very quick introduction to just boolean
circuits and sort of the problems we're
thinking about here I'll compare
circuits to algorithms in the usual
sense that people learn them and then
I'll talk briefly at the end about how
circuit analysis algorithms can imply
circuit limitations okay all right so
bullion circuits look you know something
like this so this is a boolean circuit
which is taking three bits of input okay
it's taking the aunt of each pair of
bits and then taking the or of those
bits and so it's outputting a and B or B
NC or ANC okay in general a circuit of
size s for us will take a fixed number
of zero one inputs and it will output
let's say a single bit you can
generalize it to outputting mobile bits
for SS a single bit
then for F times it's going to take two
previously computed bits maybe some
input bits such as here a and B and you
compute a function of those two bits and
that will be some new bit that I can use
in subsequent computations such as here
I'm taking this or if those things okay
so just to give an example this above
circuit on three inputs outputs one if
only if at least two the inputs of one
okay now the size of the complexity of
this circuit is going to be like four
four gates in it and so this is how we
can measure computation but for finite
functions so it's important here that
the number of bits of input is something
finite okay and then we can talk about
if I want to compute some given function
how many times do I have to take some
previously computed bits and give up
another but before I finally get the
output of the function I want okay and
so trying to minimize this as the number
of little no gates you have in here is
the core problem in certain complexity
all right so most functions most require
humongous circuits okay so a very old
theorem of Shannon and matched by loop
on/off says it with high probability if
you randomly choose a function by just
sort of flipping a bunch of coins
generating a function by coin flipping
this will require a very large circuit
but still gonna nearly a size like to
the N over N okay it's another number of
inputs to this thing so this is just
saying I take a bit zero one and you
know I take n of those bits and I output
a single bit okay so in fact every
function has a circuit of size about to
the you know gram okay so this think of
it this way so both um I'm flipping two
to the N points and I generate some very
very long two to the N bit string this
is just defining some function f okay
what this is saying is that there's no
way in general
with high probability to compress this 2
to the N bit thing and
a small very small representation this
is basically proved by a counting
argument is too many small series too
few small circuits and too many randomly
chosen functions so a random one is just
not going to be represented by something
small there's a simple incompressibility
type argument so okay the universe is
littered with you know these really
really hard functions from the
circumflex II point of view my question
is which natural functions ones that we
actually want to solve exhibit this kind
of exponential behavior they require a
large number of gates in order to
compute them okay so this is a very
central question in certain place you
just trying to understand which
functions can be solved at all we know
that random ones cannot can we can we
get is there some function of interest
you know that we that we that doesn't
have that we cannot to solve the small
sir okay that's it so that's a sorry
complex see that show so the kinds of
things I want to do is circuits I is I
want to analyze them so I'm going to
talk about computational problems that
take a circuit encode it in some way as
an input and compute something on that
circuit so the circuit analysis problem
is a problem where the input is a
circuit so here we have some logical
circuit written down in some encoding
the P that our program can read and we
want to output some property of the
function computed by this circuit so we
want to know something about what
function is it computing in you know
inside this little description so the
canonical example of this is a circuit
satisfiability problem also known as
circuit set okay it's really like the
simplest circuit analysis problem in a
particular sense here you're given a
logical circuit see so you wrote you've
written down some description of some
circuits got wired together in some
funky way and you want to know is it
computing the all zeroes function is it
the case that no matter what input I
give it is always going to print zero or
is there some input which will make it
print
one okay that would usually when
something makes it print one we call it
a satisfying assignment and that's the
origin of satisfiability but really want
to know Jesus is it computing a trivial
function or not so just tell me that
okay so a circuit set is a so-called
np-complete problem and so it's very
unlikely to be solvable efficiently okay
unless P equals NP okay like this so
probably we're not going to be able to
solve this circuit analysis problem very
well but we could ask still if there is
some way to solve it faster than the
obvious self what is the obvious
algorithm just try every possible input
to the circuit okay so here we're
leveraging the fact that there's a
finite number of inputs so the circuit
has a finite number of bits coming in so
you could just if it's got n bits coming
in there to the impossibility is just
try them all see if any of them make
this thing print one okay
so we can answer this something faster
this obvious brute-force search our okay
we and maybe this is an interesting
question
maybe it isn't I always thought it was a
very interesting question turns out it
actually is interesting for other
reasons it actually is connected to
circuit complexity but just the question
of it you have us you have a silly
algorithm you have a obvious algorithm
is it the best you can do this is just a
very fundamental question by itself all
right so that's a quick introduction to
circuits okay now I want to talk about
how circuits compare to algorithms so in
the usual everything model where you
think of you know writing a single
program it's going to solve a problem
you have some finite description of some
program and this program can take an
arbitrarily long inputs and still solve
the problem okay if you give it an input
of length 10 no problem input of length
of thousand no problem a million no
problem
100 million no problem this thing always
solves the problem single thing okay
that is in contrast with the circuit
model where we only allow you to take in
fixed length inputs okay so so if we're
thinking about how our
circuits can relate to one another we've
got this sort of correctness type
mismatch where algorithms can take an
arbitrarily long input and circuits can
only take in the fixed length inputs and
there's a very easy way that complexity
theorist came up with sort of unifying
the two and the idea is to talk about a
computational model called a circuit
family the circuit family has is an
infinite collection of circuits
infinitely many and you have a circuit
on one bit of input a circuit on two
bits of input circuit on ten bits of
input for every possible size of input
you've got a circuit with that many
inputs okay so for each end you have a
circuit C sub n that's going to bring
you on on inputs of lengths in and so
it's obvious what I'm going to do and I
want to compute something I'm you give
me an input I measure its length I feed
it to whatever the circuit is in the
collection that matches that length as I
run it it gives me some answer okay
that's how the circuit family would
compute on on some problem that would
normally be solved by now okay all right
so in this model the circuit family
model programs have infinitely long
descriptions a priori
okay there is nothing bounding what
these circuits could be you get a
separate program every single time here
input changes so it's possible that you
know if your input if your input is you
know a thousand there's something really
clever you can do just when in facility
two thousand one thousand and one you
gotta restart everything do something
completely different and get something
you know very good okay so that there's
this infinite description can be really
really powerful okay but our notion of
efficiency here is this class P poly so
efficiency for algorithms is just the
class P P poly is a set of problems
solvable with one of these infinite
circuit families so separate circuits
ease of in for each input length where
for every end the size of the in circuit
is some polynomial in it
this polynomial is fixed once and for
all let's say it's N squared and so this
circuit sees up a thousand be a thousand
squared sighs okay so this is our notion
of efficiency here for this or infinite
model okay and the idea is that each
circuit here it's going to be small
relative to its input but you get a
separate circuit for each input length
that's sort of the extra thing you get
you get this infinite description okay
so this circuit family right here
alright that's a notion of P poly so you
anything programs have infinite link
descriptions huh excuse me why study
this model
okay Theory dork that's all fine and
good but why don't you go play off in
theory land well all the rest of us go
change the world okay okay well I have
an answer for you all right okay so so
proving limitations on what circuit
families can compute is a step towards a
non asymptotic complexity theory a
complexity it doesn't talk about
polynomials or Exponential's or whatever
when have you talked about numbers how
big does the computation get if I want
to run it and if I want to run it on
inputs of length a million can I fit it
inside the known universe so so concrete
limitations on computing within the
known universe is would be is the the
thing you would like to have that's sort
of the ideal thing you would like to
have something not as I'm sorry we don't
care about polynomials exploration we
just want to know how big is the
computation gonna get so think something
like any computer solving most instances
might tend to for a bit problem these at
least 10 to the 125 bits to be described
so if you've got you know this kind of
statement then your problem is just
simply not solvable
period okay so actually such a statement
was proved by Meyer and stockmeyer in
the 70s for a particular logic problem
and they derived it we by reverse
engineering a circuit lure about because
circuit lower bounds are actually
explicitly considering the trade-offs
between the size of an input and the
size of the computation you got a
throw at the input to solve whereas
Peters MP is actually not talking about
this time at a fixed algorithm that's
gonna work on all inputs okay and so the
universe turns out stores a less than 10
to the 125 bits this is the this is the
famous bekenstein bound in 1970s
let's derive from that and so what
you're saying is that any computer
solving most instance my problem just
won't fit within the known universe okay
that's a pretty good lower bound okay so
that's the kind of thing we would like
to have and so the circuit family is
just some stepping stone to getting some
non asymptotic things were just talking
about numbers that is the ultimate goal
we are really this is des soon okay all
right so a lot of algorithms compared to
circuit families okay so we define this
thing how does it compare to the uniform
one program during low so if you got a
program that runs and say T of n time
when inputs of length n so in the
squared time then it's well-known that
you can always get a circuit family that
will do the same thing and it has about
TN in size as well there's some extra
little factors don't see it in size so
you can simulate efficient albums with
efficient circuit families okay so time
will scale the size all right so so
that's all fine good in fact if you flip
random coins in your algorithm and it
gives you the right answer with high
probability you will still be able to
get infinite family no circuits has
about the same size so in a sense you
can remove the RAM this when you allow
for an infinite circuit fan this is
nothing more than the statement okay in
complexity theory terms that bvp is in P
Polly randomized phone real-time as
efficient bonafide circuit changes okay
suppose I'm just looking at circuit
families I want to know can they be
simulated by algorithms well turns out
there is a family we in fact every
circuit has size about in some linear
size circuits
so there's definitely in ppalli there's
only a linear size as so
as the input gross it's only just grows
linearly in the transit slice however
that family has no algorithm at all okay
there is just simply no algorithm that
will solve the problem that is solved by
the circuit family okay so you you can't
like hope to make them equivalent okay
the main key here is that the circuit
family gets an infinite description you
get a different circuit for every input
link and here you have a finite
description a single element right and
this is just a statement of some
undecidable problems in fact many of
them are in P poly okay so undecidable
meaning there's no our at all
that's just technical so finally I want
to talk about okay suppose you've got a
really complicated algorithm what what
can you say about the size of the
circuit family solving it so let's
suppose I have some album running in
exponential time so to the in step so
given an in bit input it takes to the in
step so like something just solving the
trivial rm4 circuit set so I'm just
going through all possibilities through
the the inputs and just seeing what
happens okay so it's actually open it's
an open question whether every
exponential time algorithm I'm saying
extraordinary amount of time can be
solved by circuits with a circuit family
with N squared size every circuit has
this is this is a really really
remarkably open question
so is it somehow possible that extremely
long time consuming computation can be
split up into implementing tiny little
you know chunks we're on every single
input length when I solve that problem
optimally I actually get only N squared
amount of computation this is possible
it's actually possible we don't believe
it's true but it's still a possibility
we cannot rule it out and this is saying
in complexity terms that X in ppalli is
an open question so exponential time
being in poly size there is the open
question okay so just to give you
just a even more crazy way in which we
still don't know how like the power
circuit families talk about exponential
time versus shallowness some of you
might have attended ms or a workshop on
neural net okay this is also we don't
want shallow Nets here so this is a very
very shallow neural networks so suppose
you've got an algorithm and this
algorithm is solving a problem that
solvable in so-called non-deterministic
exponential time so this is like some
just gigantic unfathomable class so this
is problems where the solution takes
exponentially many bits to describe and
then verifying the solution is
exponentially so this is just some
gigantic class of problems ok the
solutions themselves are gigantic and
then verifying them takes a gigantic
amount of time ok so this is a huge
class of problems so it's actually
possible this is gigantic class problems
every single problem in this class could
be again simulated by an infinite family
of circuits one for every input length
with the following property so this is
zooming in ok so every circuit looks
like the following very very simple
object okay we've got N squared neurons
here and so in some layer we've got n
inputs so this is the amp circuit so
it's going to take n inputs and output a
bit and then from those n squared
neurons they're gonna give me a 0 or 1
and they want to take one more neuron
some function of those and output 0 1 ok
so if each neuron
we're just computing some linear form of
the input so there's some weights here
being some real weights being multiplied
to 0 one values we're checking whether
that exceeds some particular threshold
value let's say T part if it does we we
fire it doesn't you know what if it
doesn't we fire as you just this very
simple activation function okay so these
are neural networks with one hidden
layer small neural networks with one
hidden layer there should be a very very
weak class ok in fact if the weights are
really small the weights are like minus
1 1
we do have very strong Louisville but if
we allow the weights to be anything we
want this is still possible it's a
gigantic gap in our knowledge so we
don't yet understand very simple neural
networks
okay just even things like just one
hidden layer just one hidden layer with
a simple activation function it's so so
I like to just give an analogy here of
an alien brain versus implementing for
libraries okay so so think of this not
as a central time thing is as you got
some super advanced you know alien brain
no no think of it is like something
times 100 that okay something just just
some brains and solving problems
unfathomable to you okay okay but it's
one brain it's just one of them okay and
that you want to know if there are any
mini little fly brains you know just
just one just two layers of depth you
know
anslee many of them though which will
also solve the problem no matter what
this no matter what the the big alien
brain okay so this so the only advantage
you have is that there are implementing
our brains and there's a different for
each input length is that enough almost
certainly not but it's the implementing
that's that trips us up alright okay so
now I want to talk and remaining turn
about how certain analysis algorithms
can actually imply circuit limitations
so circuit islands algorithms can imply
cellular balance and particular
situations and in a particular sense
this was well known a long time ago
there's a theorem of car flipping and
Meyer from 1980 which says suppose we
had extremely efficient circuit now
serums like basically perfect
sureños arms okay so then there are
problems solvable by hours in
exponential time say to the end time
long enough time that cannot be solved
the polynomial size circuit family so
this would resolve this X and P poly
question we were talking about really
okay so just a notation if P equals
empty say circuit side is in P that is a
good circuit an office algorithm then we
would have it this class X was not in
people okay this is a very interesting
implication very interesting that that
an algorithm analysis could even the
other P would be okay that's part not
gonna be there but some error analysis
can actually prove a lower bound can
actually lead to a lower bound at all
okay but the thing is we don't believe
that hypothesis is true so it's kind of
like saying if pigs can fly then pigs
can wink I mean like we we don't believe
I bought is this we expect the
conclusion to happen okay so so it's
it's you know it's it could be useful
but it seems to be a limited utility it
seems like we have to assume you've got
like this amazing like circuit analysis
algorithm let's go study that I mean
okay maybe extra people not in people
ollie happens but okay this is you know
by far the more interesting of the of
the tooth to me okay so so what we want
to do this you know take the wings off
this i'll just dude and you know bring
him back down to earth and like maybe
maybe he can like you know like a lot no
you know something that is actually
possible and then you know we can prove
something that we expect anyway yeah so
a lower a circuit lower about that
that's what we would like to do alright
and so we were able to do this in
particularly restricted situations so
this is work of myself and many others
who are working on this too and and a
very high level what we can say is it a
slightly faster algorithm for the
circuit set problem just slightly faster
than exhaustive search already implies
lower balanced against circuits solving
these problems gigantic class
non-deterministic exponential time this
class were which like it's possible that
even neural Nets is one hidden layer
could just solve the class so in
pictures what we're saying is that
suppose you know I'll give you just some
arbitrary circuit well and there's some
way to inspect this circuit
and you can find an input which makes it
print one whenever it exists yeah and
the one extra thing I want to say is
instead of taking say the exponential
cost of two to the end time as you would
have exhaustively you take to the end
over end of the ten time okay and you do
this for all polynomial size circuits so
let's just say you do this for every
circuit in particular s you shave off
some polynomial into the tenth is enough
okay for for our purposes suppose you
can do that just a tiny sliver off
exhaustive search then you'll be able to
prove for the same circuit class that
there it that it cannot compute sorry in
X cannot be so so X is not in people
okay so so what's the intuition behind
this the there's two part the basic
intuitions what is it faster circuit set
algorithms uncover a weakness in and
what circuits can do so in particular it
says it high-level that small circuits
can't offer you skate the all zeros
function they can't hide it from you so
I suppose this where a black box okay
and you can't actually appear inside the
circuit and look at what's going on the
only thing you can do is take inputs
stick them in and get outputs that's why
that's the only thing you could do and
now you want to solve this a problem you
want to know there's an input which
makes the circuit print one right then
you can prove that you you would need to
call this black box at least to the end
times to know for sure by there ways you
could trip up any particular strategy
for querying this black box getting
inputs and outputs without looking in it
so that you've got to take to the end
time so if we can solve the problem into
the end over a ten time then there is
some fundamental way in which we are
opening up the guts of this circuit and
getting some advantage over a black box
and turns out this little advantage this
weakness in circuits of the algorithm is
uncovered is already enough to start
proving the lower bounds
alright so that's it that's the first
intuition for why is such an implication
should even hold
the second intuition is that faster
circuits set algorithms show a strength
of faster than to the N algorithm so
they saw some tasks that you didn't
think could be done namely find an input
which makes the circuit print one it
does it faster than to the end so
there's some nice algorithm that can
efficiently tell us when a given circuit
computes the all zeroes function so so
given these two intuitions you can think
of this problem in general as some kind
of gain between ours and in circuits
there's a circuit set problem that
algorithms would like to solve and there
are circuits that are you know
inherently devious and try you know
trying to fool any given algorithm and
wired in some way to keep the algorithms
from telling whether it's and when we
can be exhaustive search we are winning
the game the algorithm is winning the
game and no matter what circuits given
it can somehow drill down through the
back black box and and get the answer
okay so with the algorithm winning the
game we running a lesson to the end time
we hope to say circuits or a week less
than to the entire albums are strong and
somehow we're going to turn this into
some function in non interesting
exponential time that doesn't have your
smallest area so now the circuits
algorithm is showing that circuits are
weak and this theorem is more less
making that formal ok so we can actually
apply this kind of theorem to prove
lower bounds for restricted classes of
circuits see fancy see ok I won't go
into what the definitions of these
things are but the the way in which
they're proof lays out exactly as you
might expect we show that faster
circuits at algorithms for this for
particular classes can imply circuit
lower bounds for that particular class
ok so just some generic kind of theorem
if see circuits sat on circuits with n
inputs can be solved and to the N over
in ten steps then this class in X or
some function this big class in X it
doesn't have circuits all that kind
whatever it is that we prove this
circuit settling for
okay and the second step is just design
the element now this is just an in
conditional sort of thing so just we can
prove for many interesting certain
classes ones will renew no lower bounds
whatsoever we can solve the SAP problem
faster than exhaustive search and then
plugging that into the above connection
you get lower bounds for them so you can
improve over exhaustive search in some
cases and so far this is kind of the
only way we know how to prove certain
lower balance is through the design of
the right kind of set over all right so
I'd like to conclude with the following
challenge so how do we become smarter
about computation so the outsiders it
may seem that we already know maybe too
much about computation like computers
are getting smarter and smarter than us
all the time yet from the theory level
we actually don't know precisely how
powerful that we are understanding this
is really coarse so the dirty secret we
still don't know too much about the
limits of computers so how can
algorithms help prove lower bounds so
this is just in general a direction I
would like people to think more about
what kinds of algorithms could help to
lower bounds because if we can set
things up in this way then the lower
bound problem does not become so
intimidating anymore it just becomes the
problem of designing the right kind of
our something that we have done as
computer scientists for many years and
then how can lower bounds help design
algorithms I didn't have time at all
here to talk about how that how the
connections of that form but there are
there are many such connections namely
in this thing I briefly mentioned about
how lower bounds can imply D
randomization removing the roundness
from algorithms and making them fully
deterministic there are many more
connections to be film I'm sure so just
earlier this year my student Brin more
Chapman and I showed that lower bound
circuit lower bounds can in a particular
sense be equivalent to a particular
design problem so you prove a lower
bound circuit lower bound if and only if
you desire
test data for testing whether a given
function of given circuit computes a
particular function okay so trying to
minimize the test data you need to test
whether a circuit computes of function
is actually equivalent to proving a
lower bound so this is very nice in the
sense that that it gives a very
constructive way of thinking about how
you prove an impossibility result a very
algorithmic way how you do and so in
general I think we will make serious
progress by studying alguns and
complexity as a whole and not as
competing fields for anything we're
really doing I really think we're doing
a lot of the same thing more than we
think okay that's all I have to say
thank you
sorry can you repeat it again right here
oh so like the work of prasada you know
yeah I mean so I think what's going on
there is they're explaining the fact
that I'm at least to me is that
improving something is np-hard is
actually an algorithms problem and so
it's like from my understanding is you
know either
something can be done or it can't be
done you get and you get a hardness
reduction so it's so I mean in one case
you get an algorithm or you get a hard
introduction I mean in both cases you
get some kind of algorithm but but I
don't know I mean or any of them
unconditional I don't know
I need a lower bound you get
unconditional
yeah yeah I think it's a different kind
of instance it's very interesting kind
of instance but yeah I think I think
it's different from what I'm trying to
say but that's I didn't think I thought
you still need unique games are or P not
equal NP or something like this so I
mean I would like to say something
stronger than this so it's not just
algorithm or hardness reduction yeah yes
yes yes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
that's what makes the problem so
immensely difficult is that it could
just be anything in you know in and the
hardest case is where each one is sort
of incompressible by itself yeah if
they're uniform if there's an algorithm
generating those then you know this kind
of dichotomy I was talking about becomes
a completely different picture it was a
very different picture I mean there's
still interesting questions I mean the
open questions around it but the picture
is very different
see I thought it was very careful not to
say that I'm not trying a equals not hmm
oh so yeah I mean even at the undergrad
automata Theory level like when I teach
them my hole in the road theorem I say
well this means that for every language
either it's got a fire automaton it's
regular or there's this weird infinite
object called distinguishing set and
this proves that there's no final total
and so in that case it is some sort of
constructive way in which you're showing
that something is not regular something
does not have a DFA so yeah it does come
up elsewhere I just yeah I only have so
much time
yeah
yeah
there's a whole community of people that
would disagree with I mean that solving
is quite an enterprise actually yeah
yeah
oh well I mean there are things like
this so-called exponential time
hypothesis is false so then for example
counting independent sets if it's in sub
exponential time you can prove nonlinear
circuit size lower bounds that that
connection actually carries over in that
kind so if you could count independent
sets in sub exponential time you would
get some circuit lower pal be even
weaker than the ones reported here but
you would get something if there is the
connection still holds over there but
yeah we would be great to develop
stronger connections I think they're
they're just it's just very difficult to
get your hands